all right Tay okay Tay uh where you from
urgle where'd you grow up Los Angeles
parts of
Compton what was your family
like
uh it was religious and also
uh my grandfather he he was uh he was in
the service but he was uh he was also
alcoholic and you know verbally abusive
verbally abuses which I think that is
worse than physical abuse
because if if I get hit in my eye it's
going to it's going to heal but
something that affects your
mental it's different you know what I'm
saying it takes a lot longer to
heal in my
belief yeah how would you describe your
childhood in
general I I believe it
was a confusing but
also one that
uh they're also happy times and what
Havey but I I just was a child
that probably had a opinion more than an
average
child yeah so you know I mean we're
going to church and uh and we have you
knew all about God but also going
through a era where people was getting
high so you had to grow up a little bit
faster and have your own opinion take
care of
yourself and
um be confused about some things and
some things you just knew right off the
bat that it was happening exactly how it
was
yeah what were you like in high school I
was in I was incarcerated oh you were
yeah I was incarcerated from 13 to like
two months before I turned 18 you're in
gangs and stuff like that yeah yeah yeah
I was in a gang and uh the main reason
why I had joined the gang was because I
felt that they love
me they love me became of your family
yeah
absolutely so I I feel like I had a
functional dysfunctional family if
anybody understand that
that's exactly how I felt so the gang
you know accepted you no matter what you
can it just felt like love to me of
course I was a child but in a child mind
that was probably uh little bit more
advanced in certain areas that it
shouldn't have been that is exactly why
I joined the gang and I loved
it and I felt it loved
me and he sexual abuse in your childhood
oh
yes
um my uh my neighbor here her
brother uh used to molest me he didn't
never
penetrate and I think that's why I I was
a a tom boy and went towards the Gang
part so because I had an issue with sex
because in my
family they would everybody would be
happy and uh man Domino's cards and
everything but soon as they I used to
say call on God because they oh Jesus oh
Jesus I will Happ
you that
uh after that they was they were violent
they were fighting so I Associated sex
with that so it was something that I
wanted to get away from
period
um domestic violence is a is an awful
thing that's something that I went
through to that awful domestic violence
yeah later on in my life but
experiencing it it's just like you're
going through the same
thing and it's awful and it's something
that doesn't
uh uhuh it's not in the spotlight or
what have you but it's awful and a lot
of people go through
it and and you probably wouldn't want to
because okay you rough and you're
tough and uh so it affects you in a
different
way you think the fact that you went
through
it you you went through the childhood
you did kind of allowed you to have
relationships that
were kind of had had
abusive you behaviors as part of the
relationship you know probably probably
so probably so because maybe it's
something that you're used to you're
used to it you know what I'm saying it's
something that you something that you
used to
so but but in in in in that um it was I
never been in a whole bunch of
relationships because of things that I
witness and sayen
so it I just was uh I I want to say
paranoid but you can say
that about
uh being with a man or what have you and
and um going through that so I took on a
tomboy aggressive type of situation
Within
Myself to avoid somebody being attracted
to
me you been in love before yes one time
it's one individual in my life that
actually show and that wasn't into I got
in my 40s
uh
uh that showed me things that i' never
seen you know horseback riding different
things that when he took me away from my
area it was like everything was
bright and when I had to come back it's
like all the color drained out of
me and that turned into something real
awful once he relapsed I was he was my
ex fiance he was he a beautiful not on
drugs that that I still love him today
we've been separated or broke up for
about two and a half years now but I
cannot let go of who he
was you know and so but you know you all
when you go through this type of stuff
you think
about what did I do you know why I'm not
good enough enough or I will have you
you
know but it's not
you it's it's them because you did all
you could thank you my bad
y'all I don't want to
cry I
don't
um so probably so probably
so how'd you get introduced to the to
the
again
uh just living in a neighborhood and
seeing the other people other kids my
age and then conversating with with them
because and you looking at them seeing
how the connection is and everything
else and and then not only that you want
to
uh I want to say go to a dark side
because you are fighting against things
that you went through so so you you you
don't want to hurt so you're going to
take on a Persona of being
tough you know what I mean building that
brick tadian wall
that allows you to duck behind it so
that that feeling don't come towards you
you know so like a
shield so I got introduced to it that
way from things that I went through what
age I was what 9 10 years old
doing sexual favors for men at 9 no no I
stayed away from that because the the uh
the gang thing started at N9 or 10 the
the the the gang thing where I was a
tomboy so I started liking
women I mean you know I mean girls or
what whatever you want to call it but
the sex thing I was um trying to get
away from because of how my neighbors
which is was my best friend her brother
you you know hump on me or something
like that and uh I always try to get
away from it but I end up getting into
it into exactly that but I had to
formate my mind format my mind
to where I wasn't
there this is that can block my mind to
believe that I'm a toally different
person and I was not there you
disassociate you hear me you
disassociate I promise you and that is
such a mental thing but that was the
only way that I wouldn't react out to a
trick or something once I started you
know using drugs and and
hoing um I had
to
disassociate myself
from what it is that I really was at
that time like you're watching yourself
from absolutely from the outside looking
in you know
yeah has it changed your view of men
doing this kind of work some men because
through the process of going through
that type of Lifestyle I ran into some
people that were uh you know searching
for the same thing or they were good and
I ran into some awful
[__] I mean my bad of cussing
but that's exactly what they were it it
comes with the territory
you know so I try to work all around my
[__] if I can go get somebody else to
do this favor or what whatever it is
they wanted or you know what I mean do a
threesome and I do as much or what have
you because I Associated sex with being
something off one bad and and and that
uh played a bad part in the little four
relationships I was in because I would
get
withdrawn and I hate it I hate it cuz
sex is supposed to be a natural thing
something good you know what I mean
something to make you smile and feel
good but that's not what this
was
clearly and drugs been part of your life
okay so when my daughter died when she
was a baby uh I was selling
dope and
uh um let's back up a bit you lost your
daughter yeah at what age she she was uh
she was 7 months old um I wasn't on
drugs or nothing when I was with her she
just was born with holes in her heart
and all the main organs on the opposite
side apparently is something her
relative and that's why it's good for
you to know who you come from because
back in the day and from my experience
they
uh they did a lot of things that that's
a part of your life they used to ho and
do all of that
so
basically she died uh
uh at 7 months old in
1994 and uh after she had the surgery
for them to try to repair the holes and
so that [__] my mind up it really did
I was I was uh 18 19 years old
19 and
uh
I I never I grieved about it but I never
really grieved somebody out there
understand what I'm
saying and uh so that right there had me
smoking
Primos somebody introduced me this girl
that I was messing with introduce me to
Primos and so that was that was a way
for me to try
to block out what it is that I was
really feeling deep
inside yes
yeah did you get past Pros huh did you
start Primos so basically um Primos are
marijuana with I didn't like the
marijuana with so I used to mix it with
tobacco and a
cigarette mixed with crack I'm I'm sorry
tobacco mixed with crack yeah which is
another another form of Primo absolutely
so then I'm around everybody that is
smoking out of antenna
socket and there's no more zigzags so
I'm what is that you know let me try it
that
way down goes
Fraser then I'm full-fledged was hitting
the
pipe so it's been a struggle on and off
all the rest of my
life you know just still still using
today yeah yeah I use on and off so I I
shouldn't even say that I yes I
do yes I do and it would be wonderful to
be a because it's different it's all
type of different addicts it really is
you can I mean of course yeah okay all
of us want something but they are
totally all different type of
addicts some people just do it because
they make them horny some people do it
to get away from a problem you know
whatever whatever it is you can I feel
like you know you don't need an excuse
after you do it once you don't need no
excuse to do it you doing it because
you're doing it it's addictive you're an
active addict even if you're inactive
addict are you active addict and I'm an
active
addict not proud of it but it is what it
is now now now people know what to pray
about that's how I look at
it yeah do you have other children
um I have two besides my daughter that
passed away they're grown did you raise
them only like about seven years out of
their life each one of them those two so
my kids are like night and day I have a
daughter that she's out there
too you know she never was around me
while I was doing it you know I hit legs
bring money to my mom and my
grandmother's house and stuff like that
but I wasn't
there for
uh a lot of lot of memories that I
should have
been being nervous and scared to uh even
be around them I didn't want to expose
them to things even though I was you
know but I never was around like my
daughter and uh she ended up being on it
too I'm not going to tell her story she
had to tell her own story when she ready
but I love them I love love both of them
they like night and day though night and
day but I love them I
do what's your biggest regret not being
around my kids not raising my kids like
I should have knowing that I could have
been a mother that I should have
been I I'm not going to be in denial
about it because it is a regret it is
something that if I can turn back to
hands of time I would go to that moment
and change everything if I knew about
what it was what I was going to
face you know I that's my my biggest
regret that was a good
question yes
sir and emotionally what do you go
through living this lifestyle oh man I'm
such an emotional and feeling type of
person is I wear my feelings on my
sleeve
um and sometime that's not good in this
lifestyle but I'mma Be Me all the time
so so the things that I go through
[Music]
are being
happy being sad totally depressed that's
why I had to take medication from uh
panic attacks and
uh
uh um anxiety PTSD some things you
know so I go through all all the things
that somebody that's that has mental
problems so they
say it's a dangerous lifestyle too right
oh
yes oh yes you had things happen I'm
nice and I'm mean but only I'm not going
to do something to somebody if some if
if you see me acting out it's because
somebody did something to me I don't
never want to uh take out something out
on somebody that don't need deserve it
but sometimes that maybe would happen
because of things that happened to
me but I'm I'm always trying to do
better I'm I'm not going to give
up I'm not going to give
up stay prayed
up you
know what's your biggest fear now is
dying before my
time dying when I'm not ready and I'm
not right with the
Lord not uh I'm sorry you said what's my
biggest fear but I have more than
one so they all up there together level
you
know
yeah you think prostitution should be
legalized
yes I'll pay
taxes you might as well
you have to take care of it when it's
sick when it's okay you know yeah I pay
taxes on it they should legalize it it's
no reason for them not to legalize
prostitution when it's already going
down and it's the oldest profession in
the world before Jesus come on there's a
lot of religious it's a religious stigma
with it yeah it is but you got a lot of
people that would want to legalize it
people that wouldn't wasn't even part of
it why shouldn't they legalize it only
reason why they don't is because they
can't get tax money from it that's what
my in my belief I don't know about y'all
I I think I think our societ why not
Legalize It you ENT trp somebody over it
they send it undercover to you and the
only reason why that that you go to jail
is because I'm not saying out loud oh I
love how you feeling on my
[__] you know what I'm saying but you
hear me quote at
Price that's I went to prison
but yeah I think our society would go
Haywire if if I don't know they legalize
marijuana look how long that took so
what's the use I feel like they
shouldn't tax tampons and Maxi pass when
this is something we can't control you
understand that part but yeah they
should Legalize It they should why not
long as you are there to file for that
what's the what's what's you know I mean
why wouldn't you why wouldn't you leave
like
[__] we should be right up on the
marijuana tell me about the the clients
that you have you work Figo Street um
shoot everywhere B go is a track so it
wasn't just figureo true going to the
gas station is a track yeah I'm
promising God that you walk to the store
you get stranded somewhere every street
that a [__] walk down is a track you
get proposition yeah everywhere you go
of course you do so you try to go with
your discernment because
who wants to but if you get in the this
is from my experience because I didn't I
have got in the car with the Grim
sleeper
before and you do not know when somebody
is a rapist killer because they turn
into a different person guaranteed
somebody know what I'm talking about
they get in the car and they're Charming
theyy they turn on you they all of a
sudden they you hit the corner and they
say you know what you remind me of my
wife that left me for a Pimp then you
know it's going to go all bad
so basically
um I try not to
uh too much get in the car with the same
race that I'm I
am but you just never know you know like
a box of
chocolates that's it so I basically try
to not be in the car with somebody
that's aggressive I just want to do what
we have to do and so you can go your way
and I go mine maybe I save your family's
life I want to look at myself like a
therapist that's what that's how it is
though yeah you could argue that you
guys are you understand that part is a
lot of people that want to get away from
which I do run into people like that I
could be anesthesiologist or what happy
that they want to get out of their
world because they have to be you know
upholding it and they have sexual things
that they can't tell their wife so
they come out and and maybe somebody
like me or somebody not like me will be
the one that will nurture that area I'm
G say it like
that and T what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your
life that everything is not as what it
seems that uh no matter what you do you
got to keep God in it I don't care how
much wrong you doing or what people
think or what happy Dad you got to give
God his
time you have to keep him in your life
no matter what you doing he he when it
rain it rain on everybody no matter what
color you are what you doing what you're
not doing how much money you got how
much money you don't it's going to rain
on everybody
so and
uh another lesson that is very important
to me is that you got to learn how to be
in love with yourself and that's not an
easy thing I'm struggling with that
right now I always struggle with
self-esteem you got to you got to be in
love with you first literally I mean
look in the mirror and turn yourself on
looking at
you that's what I believe and it's not
easy not for For Me Maybe for somebody
else but I'mma admit it cuz it's true
you teach everybody how to love their
self you know show them that they
beautiful and you don't apply that to
yourself it's
awful it's
awful cuz at some point in time and
somebody's life out
there you going to have to learn how to
be in love with you first so you get in
a
relationship this this is my conclusion
of it and this this what make me feel
like a smart dummy at times it's because
if you come with 100% And I come with
100% And we come together and what we
build together that is something that we
can divide just in case we don't make it
cuz everything run its
course yeah all right Tay thank you so
much for sharing your
story wish thank you Mark I wish you lot
of luck out there thank you I wish you
the best luck in all your
endeavors thank you very much all
right
great